we will hitch high schools have a great
little school here it's a rural area
about 350 kids 7 through 12 a great
school though our kids are interested in
bettering themselves
miss camden topman is a
reading ela teacher here english
language arts teacher particularly what
impressed me about cameron is she wants
to individualize education for each
student she knows she's jumping on the
learn storm in the khan academy as one
of her tools
the activity that you guys are going to
do next
is talking about the growth mindset i
was introduced to learnstorm this year
by one of our math teachers who was
participating
she thought that we would benefit from
the growth mindset
content and activities that came with
learnstorm
one thing i learned from the growth
mindset activities is that your
intelligence can grow just like your
muscles can grow and that's something
that really stepped with me because i
didn't know that before
this is my first year actually using
khan academy in a classroom
and i found it extremely valuable tool i
was teaching a class for students who
were trying to improve their test score
on the s.a.t and act and so we found
some specific lessons that worked really
well with them
definitely the learnstorm portion of the
program was more enjoyable to students i
think than just the regular skills
practice that they were doing they were
motivated by seeing their daily progress
on that progress tracker
[Applause]
learnstorm really helped me because it
really helped me realize that i had more
potential than i thought i did
learnstorm made made everything fun made
learning fun
learnstorm helped me build more
confidence and
believing in myself that i can do this i
don't really think i would go through
high school without it
i think the biggest impact
that learnstorm had on my students this
year
was for those students who really took
the time and engaged in the
self-reflection activities
they've learned the skill of goal
setting they've learned things that are
going to affect them their whole lives
and they're going to be able to keep
going and keep growing
the world is going digital and and we
need to start up finding good digital
resources in schools
khan academy has been the first one that
i felt like could
be a significant
a very significant part of a curriculum
here at wilhelm high school
[Music]
you